damals starb ein krieg also mein name
ist nun herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge sims 4 hier machen genau
da weiter wo wir jetzt mal aufgehört
haben uns zwar beim schlafen kannst du
vielleicht kommt mal aufwachen lukas
gerade aufgewacht sind da ganz locker
lässt sich mit seiner hand durch seinen
bademantel durch und wir sind ja noch
bei den nachbarn wie ich zusammen mit
johnny schwarz johnny johnny wurde
gerade verlassen
luca steh auf mann wir müssen los super
liegt einfach in dem weg von ihr und sie
scheint das wohl geht doch einfach
zusammen johnny was machst du denn in
diesem zimmer hat sich johnny diese ich
schon nur weil luca in dem bett gelegen
hat dass ein scheiß umarmt euch doch
nicht die da vorne am straße und luca
luka so ein gebildeter koches was wir
schon in dem ersten part gesehen und ich
vernehme ich euch mal hier da könnt ihr
schon sehen wie wir gebraucht haben ich
bin euch auch mal ganz kurz ein
das macht er ganz toll hier die küche
brennt hat sich luca die idee gefasst
das ganze jetzt hier auch mal zu
probieren denn er kann wirklich gut
kochen dass sie tatsächlich gar nicht
mal so schlecht aus und wie schmeckt ist
di luca
[Musik]
daran kommt total ab hier letztlich rang
acht angeschaut und habe wieder nach
mein kopf in der schublade geholt
ich liebe die sonne und in folien
draußen und lernspiele wie ich kann das
gerät zu wie er das macht und ich
geschlafen
[Musik]
das ist einfach so bescheuert sind heute
hier sind echt passend angezogen und
luca denn einfach nur mein gott er wird
fast überfahren luca läuft hier einfach
rum in seinem bademantel und
kaninchenzüchter total halbnackten
komplette stand der nächste plan ist mal
wieder mit johnny schwarzer johnny es
ist strahlende sonne und du denkst
anregen wir besuchen heute zusammen die
lambertz das ist ja auch noch seine
familie die wohnung nebenan
die sind auch gerade wir sind drin
johnny was ist denn mit dir du musst
einfach mal wichtig sind die bescheuert
bücher sind geil da wird man so gebildet
dabei und geld mag ich auch so gerne das
kann man sehen und papieren und jaja
finde ich auch super unterhalten sich
gerade mal seit zwölf sekunden und sie
sitzen schon auf dem bett ich liebe müll
den kann man super rausbringen und
klasse johnny allein diese tatsache dass
luca wenig die ganze zeit halbnackt
durch die komplette stadt durch möglich
ist dass nahezu schon komplett nass wie
ich mein was ist denn das hier unten
eigentlich kommt man freunde familie
lambertz ist wieder da wir können ja mal
einfach hier
uns freundlich vorstellen bei ihr sagen
als handzahm war im krieg habe ganz
vielen angenommen gebracht ein schönes
aus war ich auch mal ganz viel und doch
nicht auch noch so trug dabei und zwar
die bekannteste johnny schwarzes an
einem computer der ihm nicht gehört
diese beiden besitzer des hauses sind
überhaupt nicht überrascht darüber dass
wenigen die da sind und lukas spielt mit
gruppen wundervoll ich habe ihn dann
weggibt ist gesetzlich nicht in die
pilze gehen diese noch alle bescheuert
luca nein hätte ich meine luke 1 teams
an
und jetzt hat euch duca mit kollegen an
[Musik]
war das nicht wundervoll
das war's mit dieser forderung nicht auf
zu spielen das war es mit dieser folge
sims 4 wenn es euch gefallen hat und ich
denke ja luca du kannst es eigentlich
gar nicht aber irgendwie ist es doch ein
bisschen unterhaltsamen dann zeigt das
nur auf jeden fall mit einer bewertung
und schreibt mir unbedingt in die
kommentare was in der nächsten folge
machen soll und ob ich vielleicht für
luca einen gitarristen engagieren soll
so dass wir cool eli erschaffen können
sims ich zeit gar nicht richtig dabei da